good morning John and leaving town I'm
excited about this just got to get away
[Music]
take me home to the place I love
there's like a John Denver song about
Montana and I decided not to sing it no
why did I do that I don't know triple
Esparza narrated entirely by Jews about
with just a blinking light ray the other
one camera yourself I want to see how
beautiful my life is Katherine and I
were driving about 150 miles to a place
called freeze-out Lake every year
hundreds of thousands of snow geese
swans and other waterfowl stop there
just as the lake starts to thaw to
fatten up on harvested barley fields but
first we stopped at a farm owned by our
friends Jacob in Cork here's my friend
over there and then from here on out
it's just mostly just corn and wheat and
wheat byproducts
sure
dear
oh you're on
[Music]
will you
me in a farm me
Renault it
Jacob's gonna show me the garlic trick
what are you doing oh yeah that does not
work with the garlic you buy at stores I
have to say oh god yeah it's just like
like the most delicious toothpaste of
all time I personally hate daylight
savings time and I think it's ridiculous
and we should never do it it was created
for farmers you are farmers how do you
feel about this it's hella long maybe
okay well I'm glad we've got that
settled I think we should just take this
tape to Congress that's fun bless you
baby the early bird catches the geese as
they say so we were up early the next
morning on ERISA Montana
Rocky Mountain Front is Jenna place we
are we arrived the lake there were
plenty of waterfowl to be seen but not a
goose in sight and we were worried that
maybe they were either gone or they
hadn't arrived yet we were early for the
goose migration season but we figured
we'd take the chance and it looked like
it wasn't gonna pay off then we got
kinda lost driving around on backroads
through well horse pasture and I'd
pretty much given up on seeing whose
migration their horses though and swans
it was beautiful but then they're right
ahead of us
[Music]
time tough happy